all right took long enough President
Biden finally acknowledging his seventh
grandchild does exist Joe Biden saying
in a statement to People magazine quote
our son Hunter and Navy's mother London
are working together to foster a
relationship that is in the best
interests of their daughter preserving
her privacy as much as possible going
forward went on to say this is not a
political issue it's a Family Matter
Jill and I only want what is best for
all of our grandchildren including Navy
now that is a noticeable change from
what the president said in the past
so my name is Jill and this is my
husband Joe and uh your children may not
know but we have three children and we
have six grandchildren I have six
grandchildren and I'm crazy about them I
speak to them every single day not a
joke so guess what they're crazy about
me
because I pay so much attention to them
I wanted to ask about the trial going on
in Arkansas with Hunter Biden and the
child support of the president first
lady monitoring that and how come they
haven't acknowledged the seventh
grandchild I'm not going to speak to
that from here well you know who will
Who got failed he's he is furiously
scribbling over here as
um this is something that listen there's
been a lot of media attention and
mainstream media attention that has said
Mr very disappointing because that means
one of my what about isms will have to
be eliminated but uh can you just add
this to the list do you thin oh no no no
no Shannon Shannon you don't understand
I have to do actual work now do you
think they tricked the president by
saying do you know you have a Navy
which leads me to my next Point
um they said including Navy they didn't
say Navy
Biden she didn't get the last name she
didn't get the last name now the her
mother was on the payroll for Hunter but
she still has been rejected the last
name and that shouldn't require more
shaming by wholesome moral individuals
like me
um maybe perhaps Joe's happy it's
another head to sniff I don't know just
no showering uh but it's amazing People
magazine beat the White House Press
Corps right they beat all the hard press
why is that it's because the White House
chose that for a reason this is all
manipulated right I see right through
this but I'm happy for the kid kids got
a got a grandfather who's a president he
doesn't even know that well well uh
recent piece um I think it was an
extensive piece I can't remember the
times or or the Washington Post that
talked about the fact that she knows who
her grandfather is and so she's had an
awareness of this but Jesse this has run
counter to his Persona as a very
grandfather Lee Karen got and he does
talk about the kids and how much he
loves him and talks to him all the time
this became a problem for them I'm not
giving this guy any credit this we did
it person is four years old
it's not like oh a month ago this
happened this is a four-year-old girl he
has waited four years to acknowledge her
existence so it's it's too late this sun
is tacky he's sleazy Hunter he ran away
and hid from this paternity test he he
was on the land with Secret Service
protection in Malibu trying to like
Dodge being served and then all of a
sudden she's not allowed to take the
last name and he's giving her a few
paintings so I'm not buying this for a
second they pulled this this is hurting
Joe Biden's brand he's not the family
man we think he is right because what
kind of middle class guy has shell
companies and offshore bank accounts
what kind of Average Joe has cocaine
lying around this guy is so callous he
didn't care when all these pipeline
workers were laid off he doesn't care
about the border states or Crime Victims
he really doesn't care about much he
cares about himself so this was from
pressure from polling and now they kind
of like place it in a tabloid on a
Friday come on we see what this is well
and part of the pressure came from the
New York Times this morning Dad piece
Harold that she wrote saying it's seven
grandkids um Mr President and she ends
with this the president's cold shoulder
and heart is counter to every message he
has sent for decades and if it's out of
sync with the American he wants to
continue to lead so when the New York
Times starts calling him out on this I
don't know where else the White House
had to go I think that piece you just
mentioned was it was a big one we've
talked about it others have talked about
it as well but but I differ a little bit
I root for people and I'm happy whatever
forced him to come around uh whatever I
do agree that's a family matter but
politics plays a role because he is the
president so I give them credit for that
and I hope that the statement that they
do what's in the best interest of this
of Navy and they mentioned uh they even
mentioned Navy's mom's name in the
statement which is well then they have
to cut her into the Chinese money now
she has to get the wires now well
Kennedy I mean well yeah but it was that
he he constantly said my six
grandchildren it was almost as if he
wanted to make a point we are not
recognizing this child or at least he
didn't well and and you know members of
the administration were told the exact
same thing and they they were scolded
and their Emma always been clear the
entire time you only talk about your six
grandkids this is so well documented
this is so harmful for this young girl
and I'm going to take an even more
cynical look at this than Jesse if you
can believe that
this is just a way to distract from a
horrible week for their family this was
not just a bad week for Hunter this was
an awful week for the president who also
has a looming closed-door testimony from
Hunter's former best friend Devin Archer
that's happening with the house
oversight committee on Monday and he
supposedly is going to testify that the
big guy was very much in on it and when
he wasn't there in person hobnobbing
with some of these billionaires that
Hunter was trying to milk and grift that
he was doing it on speakerphone two
dozen times so yes this is it it is only
about Optics because if he cared about
the little girl at all there are ways of
having private conversations and
connections and there are family courts
and there are lawyers who would happily
helpfully facilitate with that and they
have never taken the opportunity to do
that so this is very thin I think the
president is in real trouble and this is
just he's just trying to salvage his
very damaged reputation and with that
coming up the queen of chaos tells Greg
about her many mug shots that and more
in the fastest hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else